how did galaxies come to have the shapes  they do was a spiral galaxy always a  spiral galaxy the answer is almost  certainly no very young galaxies are  messy and chaotic a jumble of stars gas  and dust  then over billions of years they evolved  into neat organized structures like the  Whirlpool Galaxy or our own Milky Way  our Milky Way began not as a single baby  galaxy but many what is now our Milky  Way was once comprised of lots of small  structures irregularly shaped objects  that began to merge the thing that pulls  the small structures together is gravity  gradually it pulls stars inward they  begin spinning faster and faster and  flatten into a disc  stars and gas are swept into huge spiral  arms  this process was repeated billions and  billions of times across the universe